non c'est pas possible c'est quoi c'est
quoi vous devez dire du mal de l'abbé
pierre et ses tueurs non c'est pas
possible avant moi je crois au pouvoir
des mots donc je dirais que c'est un
être extraordinaire avec et qu'il en
faut plein plein plein plein plein dans
l'univers des hommes comme ça quelqu'un
poursuit elle maître vergès vous devez
des op
c'est quoi c'est quoi ils ont pressé d'y
défendre je donnais à waze est difficile
c'est pas ma vie qu'est ce qui s'est dit
ce qu'il faut que tu trouve quelque
chose sinon moi je ne défends pas
quelqu'un qui est je trouve ci devrait
être derrière les barreaux non tu sais
ce que je lui souhaite d'accepter sa
différence et de la trouvais riche et
belle chez les autres voilà très blanc
et maintenant
m